E aí
Oi boa noite gente boa noite
estamos muito feliz de tá aqui
vamos lá
no mundo nós somos mais de 7 bilhões de
pessoas
certo o quê que faz com que algumas
pessoas elas consigam se destacar mais
que outras
Será que elas conseguiram correr atrás
dos seus sonhos
foram atrás das suas expectativas dos
seus desejos mais íntimos Será que que
teve que que será que foi o diferencial
delas será que elas resolveram correr
enfrentar os desafios fazer a diferença
Será que foi indicação foi sorte como
saber mensal de história aqui só mais
100 pessoas Cada uma com seus sonhos e
com muitos desafios
algumas vezes a gente dá muita
importância para os desafios e vai
deixando sonhos morrerem como vocês
nunca tivessem existido
e por isso a gente pede para que cada um
aqui para uma reflexão
como você tem lidado com os seus sonhos
com seus desafios
e não importa qual que é o seu sonho o
seu desafio se é conseguir uma namorada
no estágio intercâmbio ser um atleta
Olímpico o que importa é a forma com que
você vai lidar com o seu sonho
exatamente E aí nesse caso a gente tem
duas opções hoje em simplesmente guarda
aquele nosso sonho Aquela nossa vontade
deixa passar acha que o desafio vai ser
muito maior do que a gente tem condições
de enfrentar hoje tem a segunda opção
correr atrás dele perceber que o desafio
vai existir vai fazer parte da sua vida
só que ao longo do processo quando você
mais vai tentando as oportunidades vão
surgindo ao longo desse caminho e foi
assim gente e vai ser e vai continuar
sendo assim qualquer pessoa
certo nós estamos aqui por exemplo
primeiro caso aqui valdisnei não sei se
vocês conhecem porque esses casos são
muito famosos mas Walt Disney foi
demitido do seu primeiro emprego porque
o chefe dele virou para ele e falou que
ele não era criativo
pois é oi pra ela também foi demitida do
seu emprego o chefe dela alegou que ela
não tinha o perfil para televisão
bom e que ela nunca poderia estar à
frente da televisão porque ela não faz
parte não faria parte desse universo ela
não só é mulher mais importante mais
rica do Meio televisivo americano como
ela fundou o próprio canal de TV
o Cafu ele participou de 12 peneiras até
conseguir ser selecionado o jogador de
futebol ele não só foi selecionado e
insistiu nesse sonho dele como ele foi o
jogador que mais vezes participou de
finais da Copa do mundo e mais jogador
que mais vezes vestiu a camisa da
seleção brasileira
os resultados aqui eles mostram que a
gente tem que correr atrás do nosso
sonho mas a gente também tem que estar
com a cabeça aberta aproveitado as
oportunidades
esse cara aqui é o Levi Strauss mais ou
menos em 1850 pegar a descoberta do ouro
lá na Califórnia e ele pensou vou
comprar um tecido bom resistente e
voltar lá para vender barraca para os
mineiros estavam se mudando para lá
chegando lá e teve uma surpresa
toda a demanda por barraca já tinha
acabado e ele tava lá com aquele tecido
na mão só que ele ficou atrás para as
oportunidades Ele percebeu que os
mineiros estavam sempre com as roupas
rasgadas e ele falou vou pegar esse meu
tecido resistente fazer uma roupa com
ele algumas pessoas falaram Nossa mas
essa roupa vai ficar muito feia vai
ficar desconfortável e ele insistiu e as
roupas que ele criou hoje só as peças de
roupa mais vendida na história da
humanidade que é a calça jeans e
provavelmente a maioria das pessoas aqui
tá usando
e fala também que aproveitou das
oportunidades foi esse aqui o David lá
em Nova York ele vende livros e
enciclopédias batia de porta em porta e
ele tava tendo melhorado vendas dele ele
pensou vou levar um brinde vou levar
perfumes para o pessoal e começou a
fazer esses esses dois junto com os
livros em pouco tempo ele viu que a
procura pelos brindes estava muito maior
do que a dos livros e ele percebeu que
ele podia fazer um negócio daquilo hoje
a empresa dele Avon e é a maior empresa
de cosméticos de venda direta do mundo
nosso último caso aqui é o Fernando o
Fernando ele começou a vender no poste
futebol que ele costumava a mão mas aí
percebeu que ele podia reaproveitar As
madeiras que iam para o Lixão da
Estrutural
mas para falar a verdade a gente vai ter
que ir aprofundar muito mais na história
do Fernando né ele vale muito a pena
gente é uma pena do Fernando não está
aqui me convidou Mas ele tem mil
atividades e não foi possível a gente
vai aproveitar e a usar um pouco disso é
o Fernando ele é um grande sonhador tem
muitas expectativas mas infelizmente
quando ele ainda era jovem Ele foi preso
aos 27 anos ele foi parar na papuda e
foi condenado a 19 anos de prisão
desses 19 por Bom Comportamento ele
acabou cumprindo 93 de um sistema
fechado três no sistema semiaberto e
três no sistema aberto
quando ele saiu da prisão ele tinha um
sonho mudar a história dele mudar a
história da família dele que a família
dele voltasse Acreditar nele e que
principalmente que ele também
conseguisse mudar a história da região
dele da Comunidade
Oi e aí o que que aconteceu agora vocês
imagine eu com 30 anos saindo da papuda
ele tinha um ensino fundamental completo
que ele completou lá dentro não tinha
uma profissão e aí vocês aí eu pergunto
para vocês vocês acreditariam que essa
pessoa teria sucesso provavelmente não
isso eu disser para vocês que segundo o
Conselho Nacional de Justiça setenta por
cento do seis detentos acabam voltando
para cadeia seja por falta de
oportunidade ou por não ter se
regenerado fica ainda mais difícil
provavelmente né Fica não dá para
acreditar que essa pessoa poderia
conseguir mudar a vida e ele não só
conseguiu isso reconstruir a vida dele
transformar a história dele transformar
a história da família dele como hoje em
dia ela influencia mais de 80 pessoas
que hoje trabalham e que ele gera
emprego e com todo esse contexto social
desfavorável o Fernando ele decidiu ele
correu atrás do sonho dele e ele montou
a cooperativa Sonho de Liberdade
com tinha comentado eles começaram
primeiro
costurando as bolas né foi até uma
técnica eles aprenderam lá na papuda mas
o Fernando um grande empreendedor com
aqueles outros que eu comentei ele ficou
atento para as oportunidades e ele
começou a ver que toda hora passar um
caminhões abarrotados de madeira para
jogar elas fora no lixão nessa atual
desperdiçar mesmo e aí ele começou a
parar esse caminhão dele falar se eu
pode destinar isso lá para o meu terreno
E aí ele começou aproveitar essa madeira
o engraçado desse terreno dele também é
que esse terreno ele utilizava antes da
desmanche dos carros que roubava
agora é utilizado por bem utilizado para
cooperativa Tô sim Imagina só se ele
tivesse se apegado a todas as
dificuldades não tivesse corrido atrás
do sonho dele talvez aqueles 8 e
estariam hoje aumentando aquele
indicador que a gente mostrou e talvez
também nem eu nem o Tiago estaremos aqui
para falar para vocês porque foi dos
Sonhos dos Desafios que nós três nos
unimos E aí você deve estar se
perguntando tá como que essas pessoas de
contexto estão tão diferentes acabaram
se juntando né o Fernando que nem eu
falei com vocês recentemente assim que
ele saiu da cadeia estava trabalhando lá
na cooperativa para conseguir construir
esse sonho lá na estrutural eu estudante
daqui da UnB ainda prestes a me formar
em design e o Bruno administrador né
Teoricamente parece nem nossa história
em algum momento é esse cruzar mas
infelizmente a gente teve essa
oportunidade como eu falei eu tava
terminando o curso de design e eu tinha
como temática do Design socioambiental
que a gente a mente você conseguir
trabalhar junto com a como comunidade
você pensar no meio ambiente de uma
certa forma você conseguir integrar isso
tudo quando eu já tinha um trabalho
anterior lá que eu trabalhava no lixão e
não conhecia O Fernando até então
eu comecei a desenvolver trabalho todo
mundo começou a comentar de uma
cooperativa que tava crescendo você
rendendo uma cooperativa de detentas que
eles tavam com interesse em trabalhar
juntamente com madeiras e eles só vão já
outros utilizando isso eu tinha começado
uma de uma certa forma comercialização
desse material e aí eu falei pô preciso
conhecer essa pessoa incrível todo mundo
fala tão bem né Então finalmente eu
cheguei Visitei lá cooperativo Fernando
me recebeu de braços abertos e ele falou
e contou um pouco da história dele
contou a história daqueles cooperados
daquelas famílias estavam ali por trás e
ele falou Thiago a nossa linha de
produção é essa a gente trabalha com As
madeiras desse dessa forma e a gente
produz hoje a gente Rezende essas
madeiras em forma é a forma da madeira
mesmo bruta ou a gente faz e faz Estacas
para vender que esse período aproximado
era em 2010 o primeiro contato que eu
tive com ele e ele estavam trabalhando
no período de eleições então estamos
fazendo muitos piquetes assim para essas
propagandas que a gente vem no chão né e
ele falou olha a gente acaba a gente tem
uma linha o que isso aqui para fazer
isso e gente gera sei lá um dia de
trabalho a cada fase do desse aqui
vendido por volta de 10 15 reais então
se você conseguir trabalhar nesse
material desenvolver e agregar valor foi
ele que virou para mim falou dessa forma
ele tem sempre uma consciência incrível
sim
agregar valor desse material de alguma
forma para a gente vai ser muito bacana
e ela aceitou o desafio para mim foi
ótimo porque eu tava buscando justamente
as inspiração como trabalho de conclusão
eu queria validar o que eu tava
estudando até então e botar isso na
prática né E aí trouxe esse material pro
bebê enfim estudei levei para outros
marcenarias conversei com marceneiros e
tudo mais e aí resultou que eu acabei
desenvolvendo
algumas acabou gerando uma linha de
móveis com esses com essas madeiras e
beleza até então tava bacana tava tudo
isso aqui uma outra coisa outro desafio
que o Fernando tinha apontado é que se
esse material depois nos converter esse
comercialmente para cooperativa não
seria interessante porque tem 80
famílias ali no final do dia eles
precisam ter o dinheiro lá para
continuar é firme né E aí eu não tinha
normal comercial a cooperativa de uma
certa forma não saberei colocar esses
móveis da forma mais adequada no mercado
e é justamente dessa oportunidade que aí
chegou o Bruno para nos ajudar na época
tava dando consultoria de marketing para
Empreendimentos sociais eu já tava
acompanhando de perto a cooperativa e eu
via todo o potencial nessa linha de
móveis então eu sugeri para o Tiago para
gente abrir uma empresa para ser
responsável pela comercialização
aí a gente foi apresentou a ideia para o
Fernando ele achou ótimo porque é isso a
cooperativa não tinha o normal e também
era difícil para ela parar a produção
para ela tentar vender os móveis
então foi assim com isso que a gente
resolveu montar a nossa empresa e criar
barulho é muita gente falou Para gente o
cenário não é tão favorável vocês vão
passar por dificuldades e esse muitas
vezes elas estavam certas a gente passou
por dificuldades
aqui por exemplo em Brasília a
mobilidade no serviço público né É aqui
não tem um polo moveleiro forte como tem
no sul ou como tem em Minas e trabalhar
com uma cooperativa é completamente
diferente do que trabalhar com uma
empresa é um relacionamento muito mais
profundo você tem que entender a
situação que ela tá você tem que
compreender cada um do momento cada
momento desse né e lógico também tá
questão de dinheiro para investimento em
maquinário mais simples mas apesar de
tudo isso a gente correu atrás
exatamente hoje em dia é nossa empresa
conta com uma linha de seis móveis mas
alguns objetos de decoração todos gente
são produzidos lá na cooperativa então
aqui um exemplo ali do pessoal
trabalhando As madeiras que eles
utilizavam ainda de uma certa forma cada
cada setor trabalha de forma
independente temos lado da marcenaria e
com o nosso massaneiro e tudo mais é
temos a felicidade hoje já de contar com
alguns
compradores clientes parceiros na
verdade que não só com e pela por
gostado move a gente queria que tivesse
esse negócio aqui que a pessoa se
interessasse mas também por toda a
história que tem por trás e ele se torna
as pessoas para gente tão especiais
porque eles acabam divulgando nosso
trabalho compartilhando e difícil para a
gente não tem preço é sim mas algumas
vendas que a gente fez temos algumas
coisas que para a gente foi muito
especial a gente vai completar agora vai
fazer 1 ano de empresa Então tudo tá de
uma certa forma para gente é muito novo
tudo a gente recebe como de forma muito
positiva aí para gente é como se fosse
um estímulo realmente para seguir
conseguimos participar já já algumas
feiras que eu não imaginava muito pouco
tá participando a gente faz para agora
no começo do ano já foi muito
interessante para a gente a gente passou
da paralela móvel junto com coletivo que
a gente faz parte chamado em três e não
só a gente levou nossos móveis é nossa
história para São Paulo como no local e
que tem uma tradição moveleira né Nós
fomos considerados o entre Este foi
considerado o destaque bom então para
gente isso realmente não tem valor final
do ano de uma certa forma fechou também
de forma positiva demais para a gente a
gente fez parte de um projeto chamado
retrato Brasília do correio Correio
Braziliense e do CCBB e fomos
considerados influenciadores na nossa
área certo e o fato da gente está aqui
mesmo é
a nossa primeira cliente que é
professora da comunicação ela foi
indicou nosso projeto justamente contar
um pouco da nossa história e a partir
daí a gente foi convidado para tá aqui
dividindo com vocês então isso tudo nos
estimula as independente das
dificuldades a seguir em frente e correr
atrás ainda que for preciso todas essas
experiências aqui que a gente teve que o
Thiago falou é fazem a gente acreditar
que é possível sim fazer uma empresa
diferente fazer uma empresa que onde
todos saem ganhando a comunidade sai
ganhando a cooperativa essa ganhando o
meio ambiente o cliente EA própria
empresa a gente tem que princípios da
economia solidária e do Comércio justo
bom e a gente gosta de resumir a Baru
como uma empresa que cria móveis que
transformam vidas muito obrigado gente